et pour finir à cette information saint
quentin en yvelines sous les feux des
projecteurs l'agglomération est un
nouveau un lieu de tournage pendant deux
jours les équipes et comédiens de la
série télé a fais pas ci fais pas ça on
tournait les deux derniers épisodes de
la saison 9 c'est la dernière saison de
la série diffusée sur france 2 depuis
vous l'ignorez peut-être mais l'un des
acteurs lilian dugois est lui-même saint
quentinois
les équipes ont tourné à l'intérieur de
la librairie du pavé du canal à montigny
le bretonneux
on écoute tout de suite lors en garde le
gérant de la librairie
ça s'est fait par hasard en fait sont
venus nous voir en disant voilà on
serait intéressé pour tourner dans mac
libre jusqu'à l'arrêt quand même un
format assez atypique et un schéma voilà
qu'on connaît pas beaucoup donc voilà on
est intéressé pour venir dont habib
hakoum bienvenue chez nous on vous avons
donc on a ouvert la librairie durant
deux jours à au tournage dont on a
bloqué toute une partie de la librairie
et c'était ils étaient une cinquantaine
de personnes entre la technique les
acteurs les figurants de la voir
apparaître justement dans des séries qui
sont cons diffusion d'insolence et une
très très bonne chose pour nous que pour
l'image chez les très bonnes choses